watch what happened here yesterday it
says 16 hours ago U.S threatens Banff
Tick-Tock Chinese owner don't sell
steaks okay this is all over the place
axios wrote it NBC wrote it they wrote
it if if and this wasn't this isn't
something that was started by uh Biden
Trump proposed this and I don't know if
you remember at one point there's a
bunch of people that were going to buy
it you know I don't know what the come
Twitter was I think one there was a
couple companies yeah I'm gonna buy this
guy uh tick tock
I I want to say it's not a bad buy but
for Facebook but I don't think it's a
good buy for Facebook because I already
got it it's Instagram I think this is a
very good buy
if Elon Musk well I
I don't think it matters who owns Tick
Tock I think it matters what Tick Tock
is connected to and if Elon buys it
he'll find it'll be Tick Tock files and
you'll see everything if if they force
so he would pull it out of there Tom 100
fill out the China look at what Vivek
ramaswani's campaign is right now you
know what he wants to do did you hear
what he said yesterday he said a lot of
things I can you go to Twitter real
quick here's what he said yesterday
which I found very interesting so you
know what vivec wants to do here's what
Vivek wants to do what Vivek tweeted
yesterday this is the kind of stuff that
your your your life is on the line so
let me find this tweet here what he said
he says if you vote me in he wants to do
to the U.S government what Twitter
Twitter Elon Musk did with Twitter files
I don't know if you know what I'm saying
they put up six feet under in two
seconds of course they would so but he
came out and he says I will be exposing
the FBI files of this files it's a very
uh uh you know what's the word utopian
yes I don't know he better not walk
through the kitchen at The Ambassador
Hotel yeah what are you talking about
look he is he's got guts he's got
audacity and I don't even mind right
there just says Elon Musk did at Twitter
as president I will release the state
action files federal government exposing
every instance where the feds pressured
companies to take constitutionally
prohibited actions I I like this this is
good but if if Elon buys Tick Tock
combine Tick Tock and Twitter I don't
know there's something attractive about
that but will Biden and his Camp allow
Tick Tock to be sold to Elon you know
that's not going to be happening they're
going to get in the way so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here